her boss confused her mood
amused her staff abused
a new report from politico which is
spanish for politico
describes the office of vp kamala harris
as an unhealthy chaotic dysfunctional
mess
much like michael loftus's outfit wow
you saw that one coming it's like a
frisbee in the desert
all right you get water yes there you go
all right enough from him
you could say it borders on abuse if
kamala we're so afraid of borders
count it
the report cites 22 current and former
vp aides and associates of harris
and president biden and points the
finger at harris as well as chief of
staff
tina florinoy according to politico
florino has been overly protective of
harris
and that's led to an environment where
ideas are ignored decisions are dragged
out and staffers get blamed for poor
results
said one source quote there are short
fuses and it's an abusive
environment people often feel mistreated
it's not a place where
people feel supported but a place where
people get treated like
s
meanwhile harris chief spokesperson
called the anonymous sources
cowards for airing complaints to the
media she didn't call them racist
but give it time oh now she is
frankly i'm more curious what her boss
thinks of this
look look look i understand the
predicament of the vice president
because i've been there man a chaka khan
might say
i feel for you i was vice president from
2008
to 1976 and i can summarize the whole
thing
with one of my famous whisper poems
i didn't do a lot i didn't do a lot but
that which i did do
i forgot
[Music]
well said joe
but i still uh feel for harris every
staff has bad stories about their bosses
even mine tell me about an
odd time you encountered with greg
well one time he told me i had to work
on saturday but then he picked me up in
his
car and took me to the center for
at-risk
youth and we read to them all day and
then he handed me this bag of gold
bars told me to give one to each of them
he said he got them from william devayne
i said there's never been a better time
to buy gold
oh i've never never had a bad experience
with greg no
he's who could ask for a better boss i
mean he's supportive
and firm very very firm
oh my god oh god yeah earlier this week
he was late for work so i went to his
house to check on him
and when i went in there was a hundred
wounded baby birds laid out
and he was chewing food and feeding them
he was spitting it into their mouths and
i was like hey dude we gotta get to work
and he's like we're not going anywhere
until all hundred of these birds are fed
but i fed every one of them
all right matt you had an interesting
boss and i
let's say let me contend that when if
you're a boss you're always going to
have underlings bad-mouthing you
is uh was it hard working for donald
trump
a little bit but you know the good news
for kamala harris is at least she wasn't
accused of eating
her salad with us with her at home
that's the good news for her but i mean
these anonymous sources they are cowards
but you know
it is to some extent the white house is
a pressure cooker
and a lot of people can't handle it and
it's you know it's it's
you're on the tightrope with no net and
that
you just have to do the job or not and
only the strong survive but
you know it's the tradeoff yeah
washington d.c smells fear the media
smells fear
president trump certainly could if you
were afraid of him yeah you knew it and
he could
and you just have to be fearless and be
unafraid of what the next
that you know knowing you may not have a
career or you might end up on a show
like this
same thing i mean look at loftus he's
hanging by a thread
and that thread is hanging from his
jacket ladies and gentlemen
uh cat um the good they said 22 sources
uh were part of this uh article you
don't even know 22 people
so you're thank god i don't i know it's
going to be a shut-in
yeah and and not only that i mean she
started with almost an entirely new
staff
right i mean people obviously don't like
to work for her i
um and you know what a lot of these
people i'm sure it's tough
but they should just be lucky that she's
not putting any of them in jail
he likes doing that even when you
haven't done sometimes anything wrong
yeah if i had the power to put people in
jail oh i would use that
all the time
[Laughter]
by the way can you put people in jail
still uh not currently no
all right he can bail us out that's why
i had him on but i can defend the
wrongly accused
excellent why waste your time with that
you know they probably did something
all right hey michael the thing that
bothers me about this story i mentioned
it earlier on a show you might have
heard of called the five
uh um i don't like it when they use um
i will call it uh bully rhetoric or
incendiary rhetoric for minor things
so when you when you hear about this
story they go oh it's an abusive
atmosphere
it's mistreatment uh toxicity as though
they're talking about that they're
living at like three mile island
you know what i mean or they're working
at the fuki yama
nuclear plant did i just say that
fukushima thank you
it was close we knew where he was he was
restaurants
downtown i just can't believe we're
talking about the vice
president's office it's in disarray how
hard is it
yeah here's what you're gonna wear to
this funeral go to the board
wake up at nine go to bed at a
reasonable hour it's so easy to be vice
president anybody in this room could
start
in an hour and we'd be knocking it out
of the park how is anything going wrong
how is anything
and you know and oh and oh there's leaks
there's leaks to the media there's loose
lips in kamala's administration go
figure loose lips
sink ships billy do you have to be nice
to be a good boss
i mean look i'm a boss people respect me
and they know if they cross me they're
dead
doesn't that make me a good boss no you
don't need to be nice i mean you need to
be fake
you need to learn how to fake and you
need to know how to which we'll talk
about that later
i should be a boss yeah but as far as
this is concerned i found this to be an
educational experience i learned a lot
from her spokesperson who's also her
senior advisor
so it's only like one person that could
handle being in charge of her um
she came out and and made a valid point
that they are not making
bunnies and rainbows right which i found
to be comforting
if she was breeding rabbits white house
there wouldn't give her much time for
like i don't know controlling the border
but then again that's not going so well
so i say make rainbows because i love
rainbows
but either way it is a hairy situation
i know i think you know what i think
this is my theory dr jill is behind this
whole thing
dr jill is feeding all this stuff we
need we need to get to the root cause
of the dysfunction in her office exactly
yes
which probably is in ecuador yes you
could probably find that in guatemala
before you'd find the actual border
solution you know what i
i think all this uh disunity is caused
by climate change
yeah and racism there's no proof that
it's not white
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else